air france associé à l'américain delta
airlines est ce que l'on appelle jeter
les bases d'une alliance globale entre
deux compagnies alors que deux autres
grands réseaux se sont déjà constitués
depuis longtemps à l'échelle du monde
jean bernard schmidt et andré germa
ils échangent symboliquement leur avion
et associe surtout leurs compagnies
respectives pour dix ans air france
voulait partir à la conquête du monde
rien de moins il lui fallait un
partenaire de taille que ses dirigeants
ont choisi delta airlines troisième
transporteur américain qui fait figure
de mastodonte face à la compagnie
nationale avec ses 112 millions de
passagers 584 avions en exploitation et
plus de 71 1000 employés une puissance
dont le pdg d'air france souhaite faire
une arme face aux concurrents la volonté
d'air france était de ne pas rejoindre
en position minoritaire plus d'alliance
existence mais de constituer avec
d'autres un très gros un très grand
réseau d'alliances en compétition avec
les meilleurs
l'accord ge est en effet les bases d'une
nouvelle alliance mondiale sur le modèle
déjà existant de star alliance qui
associe cette compagnie autour de united
airlines et lufthansa et de one world
construite autour de british airways et
american airlines en s'associant
étroitement
air france et delta airlines espère
concurrencer rapidement les réseaux
existants les autres compagnies
aériennes partenaires de cette alliance
devrait être connue d'ici la fin de
l'année